this project began with you Sarah many
years ago I wonder if you could tell us
why it took so many years to actually
reach the screen well it's taken a
hundred years for this story to reach
the screen which seems incredible I'd
wanted to do it for over a decade I mean
I didn't learn it at school and then
later when I did learn about it it seems
such a incredible piece of our history
it'd been marginalized in the history
books and it felt timely it felt like it
was the moment to resurrect these
women's stories and remember how I
fought for the vote was and also chimed
with so much of what was going on in the
world globally now Abby and Allison how
did you become involved with Sarah's
vision well the serendipity of it was
was great actually cuz I had just
finished a film of Jane Eyre with a
financier and we would have at lunch
talking about what to do next together
and the subject of the suffragettes came
up we were talking about you know things
in history that hadn't been done on film
and I was just finishing a movie with
syrup which a beer and Sarah and I and
out the other producer fair had all done
together Brick Lane and I went back to
the cutting room and said to Sarah I've
got some money to finance developing a
film by the suffragettes would you be
interested in so I was like interested
I've been like researching that for the
last five years I already know
everything there is to know I'm already
you know that's what I want to do so we
joined forces and before too long Abby
Abby came on a little wagon as well and
we were off to the races that was this
in your wavelength as well were you
thinking about the suffragettes no i
mean i think i was a bit reticent
because I just thought god it's big hats
and it's course it's and tambourines and
it's Mary Poppins and I wasn't really
and but you know I think the great and
you know often I think you're running
away from one thing into another so it
was you know we just come out in Brick
Lane and that was a beautiful world it
was very contemporary and so I thought
okay well at least I'll look at the
research and in fact the you know the
chance to it was Sarah again was a
really important part of in working with
Alison because it's such a lovely team
but when I read the research I was
really blown away and I was blown away
because two things when I was that so
much of the history had been raised and
they'd been this kind of incredible
detection work by a number of historians
and also the team itself
to start to gather together the
fragments of this extraordinary 50 60
year period and it was the variation of
material so it was everything from the
obvious news articles which were often
very condescending and we talked about
the women's hysteria and the madness of
their activity but often not reported
you could tell clearly they were often
sort of something you could see was
quite violent or epic had been reduced a
couple of small paragraphs and then you
know there was a small path a news
footage and there was some incredible
police records which had been
Declassified only in 2003 which revealed
the extent of the surveillance operation
and the level of intimidation on the
women and then it was the testimonial
some of which you saw to see within the
film that are taken as part of the
deputation and it was these that i found
particularly moving because these are
the lives of the working women and i
realized there was a sort of
contradiction between often the
laundries that you saw in the domestic
households you saw where the women
looked pristine and in beautiful shirts
and then you would read about their
conditions and like sarah says so many
things that they were dealing with you
know equal pay appalling appalling work
conditions sexual violence in the
workplace in at home custodial rights
property rights they were very 21st
century issues for women and so it
resonated originally your first draft
concerned this upper-class story which
is much more well known how did the
shift begin for all of you to focus on
this fictionalized character of mod well
we we thought it was kind of it you know
we could have told the story of Emmeline
Pankhurst's but that would have been and
there should be a story of told of
Emmeline Pankhurst but that would have
been the story of an exceptional woman
and away an examination of power and
what we were really excited by was
telling the story of an ordinary woman a
woman with no platform no entitlement
and watching her journey towards
activism because it felt like that was
the way to connect to today and often
those women are you don't hear those
stories and this movement brought
together women across classes despite
the kind of class apart ight of
Edwardian Britain you got working women
working alongside the aristocratic women
were you in consultation with historians
as well since this seemed to be
something that was just being
earth as you were doing your own
research yeah we spoke to every single
selfish a historian in the land top yeah
please I was gonna say yeah and it will
see you realize that there's this
incredible soraya T of women across the
globe who are frantically buying things
on eBay and so there's this sort of
black market of medals and suffragettes
sort of banners and newspaper footage
and actually one of the funniest things
that we saw was these tiny little cubes
of brown bread and this woman showed it
to us and we said this is amazing what
is in she said it's real prison bread
and we were like where did you get in
she went I bought it on eBay and there's
no and we looked and it was like you
sure it's not somebody just drying Hovis
bread for you and putting it by those no
but you could just see it really
betrayed the gun exposed really the huge
passion there is for the subject
actually Allison can you talk about some
of the challenges of doing a period
piece that wasn't in Downton Abbey that
really showed an underbelly of London
that isn't often portrayed yeah I mean
in some ways it's funny but I've done a
lot of historical movies and actually
portraying working-class environments is
actually much more challenging than
upper class because obviously the upper
class the aristocratic places have been
preserved there are you know castles and
cathedrals and stately homes for the
picking all over England and i've
traversed through most of them but but
to try and and and get streets that have
been untouched and to use you you can't
find them so you have to use portions
streets that you then you know work with
to create work with with with real set
design and visual effects in order to
get a 360 effect which is what Sarah
wanted and needed for the way that she
works with her actors in order to get
the fluidity that to capture their
performances so it was it was tough to
do that and and everyone to locations
people who are amazing and Fay who is my
fellow producer on this who was
brilliant at you know getting every
single ounce of production value out of
every penny it was good to be it was
actually in some ways very good that we
had a lot of prep time on this even
though the movie fell down a couple of
times while we were getting ready but
the prep time was really useful because
it meant that we could paint on as big a
canvas as possible with our fairly
limited resources Sarah talk about that
candidates how did you as a director
approach making a period piece seemed
like it was right out of the headlines
today yes what we thought that we would
break with the convention of period
films where you admire the beauty of
them because this story in what was
leaping off the page was how gritty and
difficult life was we wanted to really
put you in the shoes of a woman living
then so that permeated to every
department you know we did Alison said
tried to create these 360 sets and give
our actors quite a lot of freedom so
that we were capturing the performance
rather than staging it and often had two
cameras and in the big set piece
sequences we had three and four cameras
and then also the costumes were actual
stock and that Jane Petrie our costume
designer sourced and felt very real and
then you know carried in wash I have
seven weeks and then we had very very
naturalistic makeup and we tried
wherever possible to shoot in locations
that offered everything they could and
the greatest excitement was when we got
into the houses of parliament because no
films were very very unique opportunity
for you how did that come about well I
mean I said to the location manager we
have to get in we have to be
suffragettes about this you know and she
said no one ever has not even the Iron
Lady no one in the history of filmmaking
ever has and I succumb we've got to and
we knew that Mission Impossible was
trying to catch him and so she how did
you succeed when Tom Cruise couldn't she
tenaciously petitioned them and then
luckily they decided to open themselves
up to commercial filmmaking and then we
put in our request to take in 300
supporting artists and stunt people and
vehicles and horses and stage and
anti-government protest in the courtyard
have in the very place that barred women
for so many centuries with a
predominantly female cast and crew and
they agreed you know to their to their
credit which I thought was a major
marker of how far we've come